neighbor one this is Kevin from the
chess website calm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 1971
Canada's tournament between Petrosian
and Bobby Fischer winner of this match
does go on to face buddy Spassky in the
1972 World Chess Championship Game one
and two were fireworks Bobby Fischer
came out in Game one with the white
pieces and got the victory and the
Petrosian came back and game number two
with the white pieces and got the
victory that was Bobby Fischer's first
loss he had played 13 games in a row and
won every single game up into that point
in the Canada's tournament and then he
did face to feet in at game number two
so getting on to game number three Bobby
Fischer again has the white pieces
looking to start to pull away in the
series Petrosian looking to write the
course here with the black pieces so
we're going to get started efore pretty
common from Bobby Fischer but then II
six we see the French defense not
something that Bobby Fischer goes up
against all that often continues normal
play here d4 d5 then after Knight to c3
black really has two options could go
with the win or with Bishop to b4 or
could also just go with the pretty
standard classical and that is Knight f6
he went with the classical here at
Knight to f6 and then Bishop to g5
preparing for the pond to come see five
couple ways to really combat this one is
just to play Bishop to e7 and then later
you can bring your Knight to d7 but
decides to just go ahead and take this
material here in the center of the board
then after the Knight takes here on e4
Bishop e7 there is an exchange in the
board and then Petrosian decides to take
with his pawn and most of the time i I
see especially nowadays players will
take with their Bishop they don't want
to have double pawns here on the F file
give up the support in front of the King
if they decide to castle on the King
side this does give up the bishop pair
but both sides will have one Bishop gone
so doesn't matter if they take here on
f6 and the Queen recaptures you could
then come Knight to f3 here defending
Pond or if you wanted to just play pond
see-through you have that option as well
but Petrosian had other ideas he wanted
to hold on to his bishop Pierre so he
decided to go ahead and take with his
pawn here on f6 Fischer continued with
g3 preparing to fianchetto here on and
g2 and this really to me looks like he
expects Petrosian to castle on the Queen
side and so he's just lining up all his
material it's a point to the Queen's
headboard this setup right here from
Patterson does not look like he's
looking to castle on the Kings side so
this gives him some options as far as
getting his knight involved into the
game where it doesn't block off some of
his additional squares for his queen or
his bishop if he brings it over here to
e2 also protects the pawn here on d4 so
lots of things going into this move with
g3 we have f5 attacking the Knights that
comes back here to c3 and then a Bishop
to f6 just attacking the center of the
board here Knight to e2 as we talked
about wants to bring his bishop here and
not have that block death by his knight
here Knight to c6 just adding pressure
on the pawn on and d4 there's kind of
two ways to defend this one is to push
forward with d5 the other one which is
not nearly as good but that is to bring
the Queen to d3 so if there was an
exchange maybe Knight takes then you
could play castle to the queen side and
now you have an additional attacker on
the side of the board your opponent has
a bishop and his queen protecting it and
now White has both the night and the
Queen and the rook attacking the square
right here but Bobby Fischer decides
yeah I don't want to go ahead and do
that
I still want to have the option to
castle on the Kings side he decided to
go ahead and push forward with pawn to
d5 there's an exchange in the middle
after the knight takes the bishop comes
down to b2 and then Bishop g2 and it
looks kind of odd if you just look at
this and say wow you know this Bishop
right now is not really attacking
anything and this bishop can just take
this rook here on a1 this would be a
trap this is not something
Petrosian should take care if he does
the queen is gonna take on a one and it
just has so many threats it's attacking
this rook here on h8 so we can go over
the different variations of how
Petrosian in this spot would respond the
first one is he can castle King is not
under attack here it doesn't matter if
your rook is under attack you can still
castle through this here and so from
here we could see Knight to f6 this is
check this is also being defended by the
Queen here on a1 so the King has a
couple options if he comes to g7 well
this is gonna lose this is gonna be
checkmate there's no way to avoid this
doesn't matter where he really goes but
eventually this will be checkmate now if
he doesn't come up if he comes to
instead h8 the other option that he has
here well now bishop takes on c6 pawns
gonna recapture castle on the King side
here but there's so many threats as soon
as this Knight moves okay well he's
under attack from the Queen right here
so can't really come out we've already
seen what happens if that happens can't
come to g8 because the Knights defending
it
this Queen is defending the knight so
the Queen can't really do anything and
there's no other minor piece to really
get this night off the board so that's
gonna be a tricky spot now if instead we
come back and say well it's not gonna
Castle but let's just bring the rook to
g8 well you can probably clearly see
right away Knight to f6 this is forking
the rook check right here on 8th as well
if the rook just swings over to f8 still
a problem to deal with the knight to f6
this is check forcing the King to move
here even after you cast on the King
side you can you can tell this King is
in a world of hurt white can just attack
hit the rest of game it's in the center
of the board White has ample material
and opportunity to attack for giving up
the rook for the bishop there so if we
come back in the board state we can see
not gonna be a good move if the bishop
takes here on a1 so in step Petrosian
decides go and castle on the King side
Bobby Fischer also decides to go in
castle
on the kingside and then the bishop
comes back here to h8 recognizing yeah
this rook here on a1 is a trap and I
need to start protecting my king side
does not have as much protection as
Petrosian would like here Knight to f4
getting this not involved into the board
state also just trying to attack on the
king side of the board after Knight to
e5 we see queen h5 and you can start to
see what Bobby Fischer's looking to do
he sees weakness he's starting to attack
Petrosian trying to block that off as
much as possible bride is a bishop back
here now brings his knight here to g6
and then rook to d1 I always want to get
your Oaks involved into the center of
the board and especially when there's a
piece in between that rook and the Queen
just something that protrusion always
has to be thinking about knowing that as
soon as this Knight moves anywhere the
queen is gonna be under attack now
Patterson says yeah go ahead and move
your knight right here because I don't
want to have to worry about this for the
rest of the game here so after the
knight moves then we see the Queen come
down to f6 just really blockading most
of the attack that Bobby Fischer could
have here on the Kings side we have King
to h1 here Bishop to g7 Bishop to h3 a
lot of moves trying to attack this
square here on f5 you can see both the
Queen the bishop and the knight here are
all attacking this square here on f5 so
Pretoria recognizing that needs to get
some of his material to defend this as
well has his Queen in his bishop now he
gets his night here on e7 to also
protect this material rook here to at d3
just preparing for the rook to come to
d1 if he wants double barrel here also
adding a level of protection for his
other pieces Bishop to e6 rook to a d1
Bishop to h6 attacking of the Knights
right here
rook to d4 and then after they exchanged
the Brookes gonna recapture here on f4
does not right now want to give up the
protection he has in front of his king
by taking with his pawn gives double
pawns here on that file he wants to get
Petrosian double pawns does not want
double pawns himself so this rook here
adds another
lair of attacking this square here on f5
now we see petrosian get his own rook to
d8 my pictures is yeah we'll go ahead
and exchange material right now and the
Bobby Fischer makes the first stab at
this square here on f5 not the worst
thing from Petrosian doesn't want to
have double pawns here on the F file he
exchanged with his Knights Knight comes
up here and then rook down here to d5 so
really it seems like Black has a better
position here in the late game the
bishops gonna do better if there's pawn
chains on both sides of the board the
bishop can easily get to both sides very
easily if there's only pawns on one side
of the board knights actually do better
so in this spot I would say black has a
slight advantage here
but then after pawn to g4 pretty
interesting move as I was analyzing the
game and Petrosian immediately just
played bishop takes on f5 said yeah I'll
give up my minor piece that has an
advantage here and the pawn can
recapture now this does give Bobby
Fischer double pawns on the F file but
really if we come back this pawn g4 is
not doing too much it's gonna be
difficult to advance on the King side on
the Queen side Petrosian has a lot of
opportunity he could push here on b5 he
has three pawns to Bobby Fischer's - all
the actions over here on the King side
the board the Queen can't really defend
over here on the Queen side and this
Bishop can easily defend everything
that's going on over here so I think
there was some opportunity for black in
this position to try to push a little
more than just exchanging his better
minor piece here on f5 but he does Bobby
Fischer recaptures here pawn to h6 pawn
to h3 King to h7 just getting it off
this open aji file right here Queen down
here to e2 and then we see some
repetition from both sides it kind of
looks after the Queen comes down here
that the rook can just take here on f5
because it's only protected by one piece
the Queen's obviously not gonna take
care that would just be a ridiculous
move from black but the rook can't also
take and the reason for that is
Queen to e4 and this is going to be a
drawn game because black pretty much has
to bring his king to g6 if he doesn't
he's going to lose material here in on
this F file but as soon as he brings his
king to g6 then Bobby Fischer is going
to play rook to G for the rook can't
move because it's being pinned down by
the Queen here and the King only has one
move it's gonna come back to h7 and then
Bobby Fischer is going to play the exact
same thing rook to f4 and then the
King's gonna come to g6 so yes can't
really take the pawn here on f5 after
the Queen comes down so instead looking
for another move Queen to e5 could just
take the material but Bobby Fischer says
yeah that's not really what I'm looking
to do Queen to h5 I'm threatening the
pawn up here on f7 what are you gonna do
and would you see some repetition back
and forth no one is able to do anything
and so after 34 moves we do have a draw
so the first draw in the match we do
have Bobby Fischer with one win
Petrosian with one win and a draw but
Bobby Fischer first game that he has
played where there was not someone with
a win which is kind of crazy after 15
games into a tournament with the best
players in the world that this is the
first one that he's played where someone
did not come out with a victory but
petrosian's got to be feeling good
he first game came in lost to Bobby
Fischer everyone was probably pretty
stunned then he came back won and then
he just played a very good game with the
French defense in the black pieces he
will come back in game number 4 with the
white pieces but thank you guys so much
for watching the coverage of the 1971
taking a look back at one of the more
historic Canada's tournaments knowing
that we have the own Canada tournaments
coming up here at the beginning of 2020
I thought it'd be nice to look back at
some of the more memorable Canada
tournaments in the past so thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in round
number 4